you are smart you are appreciated
you don't need to go to the gym ever you
aren't based and totally right about
seed oils
people often wonder how they could get
hair that looks manly and sophisticated
like yours the answer is Jeremy's razor
hair and body product this has been
Georgia Howe with daily wire
I'm kind of changing my opinion on ASMR
actually yep also Georgia's got a great
voice that is what ASMR I was told does
I was told ASMR is really comforting and
pleasant and George's voice has it's
very soothing it's very hello hi hi
there I'm you're great man but
looking at some woman eating Crustaceans
and listening to the saliva saliva that
bothers me but it's